okay let's talk about that middle-class
famous tour baby those sweet sweet live
shows
about to be kicking into high gear it's
a stand-up comedy show with a little ayg
that we play with the crowd great way to
introduce new people to the show so grab
the squad grab the homies grab the bozos
grab your best girl grab your best guy
and come out and see us yeah guys uh
first date is gonna be red bank new
jersey that it will sell out get those
tickets and we're in seattle portland
kansas city springfield st louis
nashville come on then up there to indy
get your tickets like big man said it's
a great time these live shows are
bonkers you've seen the clips link in
the description do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah
i got them take that teddy
ah having a good time little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find out the girl to be clear see
just a big old piece of trash
i'm your host stage foley coming at you
on a beautiful day we're down here at
antoi's basement a little bit of a
somber mood upstairs with her oh no just
got off the phone with her lawyer okay
it turns out that they uh she's gonna
have to drop the case that she has
against uh good people at 7-eleven oh no
turns out they caught her putting the
cup of coffee in the microwave before
she threw it into her own face okay so
the lawsuit's dead but we still got the
cvs thing working out so it could be a
short house in our future my co-host is
coming at you from across the table this
is a family episode
we got to do a better screening job on
these writers i'll tell you that right
now
holy cow
my co-host is the ceo the founder the
executive producer
of are you garbage he's international
businessman he's the prince of park
avenue but always the king of the boards
baby
give it up for kj kevin james ryan
somebody's angling for a raise hey
what's up everybody thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube as you know those
numbers are turn around cooking
and then obviously head over there pull
up the computer fire up the dell the
gateway whatever you got
the macbook w w
are you garbage you can sign up you get
bonus episodes of ayg every week you get
bonus episodes of hard feelings by the
way which
is the runaway pod
of the century
golden globe nominated yeah that's like
the real behind this if you like this
show that one gets real [__] wonky
it's like gun smoke yeah a lot of
yelling a lot of finger pointing a lot
of icing it's the show behind the show
check it out yeah
if you do sign up for the patreon there
make sure you get your bit rate turned
up because there's a lot of product over
there that you can [__] download
right in right into your home right into
your brain terabytes terabytes where's
that i don't know oh sounds like uh
what's up where's that i thought it was
a restaurant
[Laughter]
trying to get a table of terabytes for
two months i dropped my name how about a
nice quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good we love them you love them
give it up for tebow t-bone mcmuffin
toby mcmullen what's up dudes what up
t-bone looking fresh looking stylish
looking chill thanks dude just want to
give a quick shout out to all the
boneheads out there
[Laughter]
who's the best
shout out to the boneyard
[Laughter]
all the boners out there oh man you're
getting a lot of love in the streets
listen i don't hate it i got to be
honest with you well i wanted to hate it
at first glance
kippy loves a good name
you're gonna be opening up for dave
matthews with a name like that hey man
shout out to lawrence at the motion city
soundtrack show
oh
man wow man that's good stuff that's a
boneheads
well put it on a t-shirt we'll see how
it does
you know what i mean maybe buy six of
them
let the market dictate the demand yeah
this is capitalism at its finest baby
yes sir gang family episode we're here
uh i went to the gastro guy today the
gastrologist over there okay you ever
get a good doctor and you're like [__]
man you're [__] awesome and it's it's
just [__] great i got a little
nervous when i walked in there when i
went to give them my co-pay 50 no big
deal
cash only
cash only at a dollar what is it a dive
bar what
where you had [__] hold hands
i'll cash only at a doctor that's no
bueno dude no [__] no no no
a dentist maybe i could see that with a
dentist but cash only at a doctor's oh
what's a credit card machine look over
there's an atm machine
whacks you over the head for five beans
for the [__] surcharge if five beans
at the machine five beans and my bank
charged me getting [__] hemmed up
that's that's like a that's strip club
stuff here's the thing there was an atm
out in the hall of course there was dude
but he's awesome man what part of queens
was it because it wasn't manhattan i'll
tell you that much this has [__]
barrow written all over it
that was a deep kentucky um that's no
good yeah i mean i get that he's a nice
guy and everything yeah he's a great
doctor though um yeah he's
gotta make his pinky ring what do you
mean that's crazy dude that's insane
shouldn't you have gloves on
nah nah we're good we're good
man
well you've been getting strange lately
sounds like you got some good insurance
over there oh man i don't
my metro card and my insurance card are
the same card yeah
my uh my wife keeps going to doctors and
i don't have the heart to tell her that
like what our coverage is
no
she's used to german universal
healthcare you go whatever for whatever
she's on there with yours yeah and i got
like
i got like i got like collision that's
all i got you know i got like just in
case i hit somebody else typically
i guess for bar fight purposes
two black eyes a year
had a boxer's break
[Laughter]
but she's going to all these dogs not
getting tommy john's surgery no no he's
the guy doing it
uh she's going all like you know she
goes for checkups and this and that and
you know was the last time you were the
doctor how long i mean i don't want to
talk about it
yeah i don't know 15 20 years you're
probably good though the last doctor i
went to ah there's a lot of which i'm
probably good then that's your lunch
yeah once you get over the hump you're
good
right
if you haven't broke down now you're
coasting the last doctor i m the last
doctor i was actually like i don't i
guess a sign too wasn't the word but my
last doctor my last like doctor i've
seen more than once put it that way
uh was my pediatrician and i went way
way too late in life to my
hit that pediatricians chest huh you
know sitting on a race car yeah it was
bad
uh but i haven't been to an actual
doctor i think i went for a physical
maybe like right when i got out of
college
maybe get a job or insurance or
something like that
trying to join the force what's going on
they make you gonna they make you get a
physical for a job no it might have been
like what are you stunt man
aren't you about to jump to grand canyon
yeah i never heard of such a thing no i
think i was enrolling on
my jobs insurance and maybe like i
hadn't had a physical in like five years
okay in order to get enrolled you know
you have to yeah i think i had to do i
think that was it they make you go but
you ever get any time you go i guess
it's older as you get older it's
different you go to a different doctor
you walk in you're like you know this
ain't what i'm used to no it's no good
man it's no good jack jack yeah other
than the atm machine and and the
cigarette cigarettes and the crabs game
going on in the corner dude don't stop
going to that guy play and play pinball
while you wait
you walk in put a stack of quarters on
the pool table i'll be back in 20. i got
next i'm in line daddy holy [__]
oh he's putting me under the knife uh in
august for what i'm gonna get a
endoscopy
get to get the pipes checked out then
we're gonna go back and do a colonoscopy
get it all worked out okay all right
well like chinese finger cuffs i got
them coming on both ends
this is very patreon content by the way
we're letting the good people on itunes
and youtube hear about your butthole
this is stuff they gotta pay for all
right that's patreon.com
uh people say that's their favorite
ongoing bit i call for a close-up and
toby never goes to it and you don't get
it love a good bit you don't put your uh
gum in your drink right we've we've
discussed that yeah no what like you
don't put it in a soda you don't like
bubble like back in the day you don't
like bubble gum at the bottom of the
soda i don't know
no that ruins the what it's like it like
makes it it makes it i understand
that's not new gum it's hard gum is soft
you always say that it makes it new
again it revitalizes the flavor
no okay it does not well by accident
well i spit my gum out in a pellegrino
bottle a couple days ago and i've gotten
into the bad habit of
just drinking
whatever drink is in the car unless it
unless there's been like old backseat
drinks yeah do you remember do you
remember that red bull you got me last
week
yeah i finished that off yesterday
around twoish
because it wasn't really that hot it
wasn't hot if it's really really hot
it's like a raccoon
for energy drinks that's yeah what are
you doing yeah
that's how you get botulism and [__] i
don't think so i don't think it's the
only thing you gotta worry about is if
it gets really hot in the car you could
the the micro plastics can get in the
water
that's already happening i think i know
don't you know it brother
we're either coming or going you know
what i mean
all right
um
yes you should stop to find a new doctor
and stop doing that okay
i signed a year contract with it before
12 month lease first list security get a
free cell phone though and i don't have
to change my number
guys this is a family episode as you
know when you sign up for that there
patreon are they the aforementioned
greatest website of all time
uh you will we will answer your garbage
question
on here
on the air that's how we do it
people are loving it thank you very
much
this one uh this is from tt jared's
tunican
shout out to chrissy d and then shout
out to chrissy d in the whole a whole
squad over there um
never had this isn't a question more of
a
story yes never had one
been here a long time ten dollar homie i
got hit by a car in eighth grade my
parents must have got the worst legal
team ever because they only squeezed the
person for 1300.
for hitting a kid
jesus christ
then my parents turned around and took
half of it to fix the roof of the mobile
home we lived in
that's bad dude you get [__] hit by a
toyota you only get 600 after attacks
talk about taking one for the team oh
yeah that's real that sucks man we had a
kid got hit
eighth seventh eighth grade
skateboarding mm-hmm
yeah [__] mulch pretty bad were you
with him
no no no no i didn't witness it uh he
got he got [__] ran over and like
he's fine now uh
shout out
uh
but he got like a couple hundred jihads
a couple hundy couple hundy what what
when his beak right then i think his
parents gave him like 10 or like he got
some cash up front because they knew it
was coming
no so like he got the settlement and
obviously when you're like [__] 13 or
14 like your parents going to go well
here's you know 400k or whatever 250 g's
so they gave him a lot he wouldn't
to play with not play with whatever get
a new bike get a [__] you know
whatever yeah i don't know how about a
helmet huh
how about some elbow pads so he got that
and then he uh
then when he turned 18 he was able to
really start blowing through it yeah i'm
pretty sure there's probably about zero
of that yeah if i had to guess ooh you
mix a perk a perk doodle or two in there
you're in trouble
man that's no good i it had to be like a
fedex or ups or something oh it was a
woman insurance cop insurance company
covered it this broad had [__] uh
usually the policy caps out at 100k and
this was [__] in the 2000s i don't
know man damn yeah i've never had jackie
childs
he got a good amount of scratch for it
it really [__] you up yeah yeah maybe
she had money too it came from that who
knows
maybe it was a nice neighborhood not
really it wasn't a little hush money it
was on the outskirts damn that's a good
racket people doing it all the time
jumping in front of cars yeah do it a
lot in europe
what they know it's russia russia
and the burden of proof that's why
there's so many dash cam videos in
russia the burden of proof is on the
driver
like if you go that guy hit me they go
all right they just like you know they
just take your word for it throw a
couple rubles your way yeah so that's
why everything that's why there's so
many dash cam videos because everybody's
like well [__] this damn yeah i heard a
lot of them oligarchs came from that
getting hit
so they made their money slip and falls
slip and fall oligarch you hit me in
your hugo [__] ship the chatter will
you
slip and fall to a nickel mind
[Laughter]
uh fantastic uh
i like the not questions this is i was
just gonna say i love the story it's a
little different and you get like
that could never be a question you know
what i mean like there's no way you
could get that level of dirt bagness
across dude it's also it's probably like
20 years ago he's still upset about the
which is fantastic
um all right
this one is from katie 10 homie never
have one red is it trash
to add the letter t to the end of cousin
i'm looking at you kippy jesus yeah i do
say cousin
cousin my cousin
it's not right yeah but my cousin
what the [__] is that where are you from
that's not a philly thing my cousin yeah
this guy's a spy you know my cousin yeah
that's philly oh yeah my cousin all
right there you go you know my cousin my
cousin mike
sells pills yeah
wears jean shorts and a white pair of
sneakers in the winter yeah shout out to
the kensington cruisers
oh man
i think i might have mentioned that i
got a brand new pair of kenzin or a
brand new pair of uh
reebok classics i thought i was this
[__] how old are you thirteen
which was your mom let you wear them
what do you mean what do you mean that's
[__] that's dope head [__] yeah i
mean dressing like a dope head patty was
patty knew all about that she didn't let
us wear that [__] well it really worked
out for her huh
she's like if i if i had on white socks
and they were pulled up to my shin she'd
freak out yeah what are you with cholo
[Laughter]
where you parked a low rider who's doing
that no one's doing you're [__] walking
to dinner and stuff
what are you talking about high socks
what's that representing
what are you talking about i just
pictured myself [__] walking through
paddy's house
putting holes in the floor
[Laughter]
i was a little kid in the era of high
socks before high socks to me
represented i i get it's a time period
but dorks you wore your socks high i
wasn't
i mean it was ankle socks back when i
was banging you know i know that's what
i'm saying these cool tick tock kids
with the floofy hair they all wear the
high socks yeah they were the high side
short shorts don't think i haven't
noticed that
i love the because when i was in the 80s
like all like like uh magic and all them
al all the basketball players they wore
their socks up to their knees and they
had the stripes on them sure yeah they
were tube socks yeah they were rubber
the red and the blue
yeah they were nice so i you know i was
caught in between those two worlds was
that drug representative gangs no no not
at all but she knew that when people
started wearing the kensington cruisers
and and the socks in the middle she knew
that that meant
you know she she she'd been she'd been a
wanamaker's christmas tree you know
she's been around the block a couple
times i knew what was going on so i'm
seeing some cd characters yeah yeah yeah
you put those things on you start
nodding out immediately
yeah yeah that's a tough look but i
walked into christmas one time i felt so
cool my cousin brandon hit me with the
kensington nice pair of kensington
cruisers i was devastated
to say the least went home barefoot man
the dudes in my family can
hone in on something that the one minor
change you've made
and say it
so like
not matter of fact but also dismissively
like you know as you're hugging him he's
like hey cool haircut you're like oh
[__] i rocked this thing just in here
for a little bit we've talked about soul
patch yeah just this
whoo
man i showed you somebody's christening
[__] thing
you look like you're on meth if you show
up to a chris somebody's
not even your knee i showed up to
somebody's christmas
it was a friend of a friend of a friend
i showed up to someone's christening
with my soul pack he was a grown man
it was in a lake man that [__] is so
weird to me that's got to be garbage
that's got to be a garbage question we i
we've talked about have you ever been
baptized anywhere other than
oh when you start getting outside the
cities they do that stuff it's probably
more religious and probably feels good
to do it game of marco polo going
not in a pool you idiot i mean they do
it in the doug smith yeah previous
guests i'm talking about crazy person
no but in a river or a pond that doug
smith's a good looking guy too sweet
looking
man he has i'd like to take a run at him
he has 1940s movie star eyes they're
that kind of blue yeah it's real like
daniel day lewis s like yeah a lot of
character in the face yeah i think i
mentioned him last week or not but uh
dylan mcdermott has those kind of blue
eyes you've been mentioning dylan
mcdermott for i don't know about two and
a half years i don't know who he is
dude's hot keeps it tight he was in
hamburger hill he was in uh always food
with you
he was an ice cream lane he was in
hamburger hill he was the main guy in
america
yeah yeah i think i guess i know super
good looking dude t-bone you got him
yeah he's the guy who's who you see in a
movie and you're like oh yeah that guy
that guy yeah i figured yeah like yeah
whatever it doesn't not to be confused
with dermot mulrooney
he can kick rocks i don't know who that
is
first name dermot that was thanks man
he's good he's good
he's not dylan i remember some kid hit
me one time in elementary school we were
beefing right you know yeah uh
going back and forth going back and
forth yapping you know
um
well fat kid like you how to keep your
mouth shut me yeah i think that's i mean
that was obviously the go-to of you were
ready for that yeah what come on
uh but the kid hit me with throw a slim
jib catch that in the air
now you're all in big big trouble
he hit me with at least my mom could
afford to buy me a last name
get that guy on the show
that's [__] nice yeah but no [__]
didn't hit it was more like what's this
guy i get that every once in a while he
has two first names it doesn't click to
me for some reason ryan though i know
it's a first name sounds like a perfect
d sounds like a perfectly perfect
perfectly reasonable last name maybe
it's the irish you've heard it so much
yeah well yeah and also too my cousin's
their last name is ryan yeah that'll do
it yeah uh
yeah for sure it's not a very common
maybe nolan ryan meg ryan
kippy kevin james ryan meg aka kj aka kj
kev yeah kev never took off kev sells
weed kev's no good no you when we go
camping you'll be kev that's a cat's a
kev party i had a picture today because
we're closing in on that [__] that
goal
and i the idea today of us going to
[__] dicks and like [__] gearing
the [__] up for that is gonna be so much
fun can we get hatches and machetes oh
we're getting everything what about
those pants that go up so you can go in
the river the waiters yeah yeah you can
shower in them if you want let's talk
about butcher box baby butcher summer
grilling season is upon us in full swing
do you want to have garbage that you get
from the [__] grocery store do you
want to have free range chicken free
range turkey wild caught salmon [__]
ground beef that's grass-fed grass
finished talking about top quality meat
all in one delivery system to your door
in a freezer get ready to go when you're
ready to grill yeah gang do not be a
bozo when you're trying to throw a
barbecue this summer you don't want to
ruin fourth of july you know are you a
patriot or what you know what i'm going
to do you don't want to get you don't
want to ruin the fourth of july for the
whole goddamn family all right putin to
win do it right uh every month butcher
box ships out of curated selection of
high quality meat right to your home
free shipping for the continental us no
antibiotics no hormones packed fresh
[__] frozen for convenience so you can
save time and money on your next grocery
store trip high quality meat delicious
100 grass-fed free-range chicken pork
raised crate free and wild caught
seafood look at that check it out uh at
an unbeatable value it's less than six
dollars per meal on average look at that
hashtag what are we done yeah there you
go uh get summer sizzling started with
this special butcher box offer for our
listeners free bacon for life holy [__]
they're doing bacon now we're back free
baking for life broncos with a
membership plus ten dollars off sign up
at butcherbox.com ayg use code ayg to
get one free pack of bacon in every
butcher box for the life of your
membership plus ten dollars off your
first order that's butcherbox.com ayg
use code ayg to claim and steal do it
now back to this show back to the show
full camo maybe an orange hat to let the
other hunters know i'm yeah no [__]
not getting [__] i'm not taking one
to the back of the head yeah and i'm
thinking i'm a rhino yeah some weekend
warrior with a 22 and a bad shot [__]
trigger happy and also you gotta be
careful with the camo too that's how a
[__] moose will sneak up on you
you gotta wear that orange [__] little
2p they're a deer do you ever see those
videos oh [__] i forgot
what [__] ticks man i ain't going
upstairs man we're sleeping in a camper
ya bozo ah we got to get some off
or some anti-tick repellent
maybe i'll get one of them collars
i got some pills at the house for hanzi
i'll feed you
take one i'm starting out you got to
take one every month yeah i don't like
kicks got deer up there
but if you peed there's deer jordan you
can buy deer urine to attract them
right i don't want to attract them i
know but hunters do that's where you can
go buy deer yeah we have buckies they
sell it yeah and they attract do you
ever see the videos like dear [__]
dudes up yeah that's all because they've
you know yeah too much deer urine yeah
put some some some deer juice on you
dudes start showing up look look at a
party yeah no good yeah we should i wish
there was a buckies around here could
really gear up at bucky's could gear up
at bucks we're gonna go to dicks or
something really [__] yeah get a fishing
pole couple pocket knives some [__]
axes couple coolers some hats
stuff like that maybe a flare gun
you don't think a flare gun we're gonna
[__] yeah we're going to a campsite so
[__] goes down we're gonna end up
shooting the neighbor
put all the snacks in a bag right now
you use it in a hold up we get hemmed up
we start puffing smoke
but
let the boys in the national guard know
are still here
come get us and bring some sandwiches
we definitely got to get bear spray no
we don't yes we do no we don't in
handcuffs
for what
sexual preferences cuff the bear
[Laughter]
okay um
all right this is a tebow one i think we
have touched on this first time a long
time from josh uh is it garbage to go to
eat at a restaurant and bring your own
hot sauce
yeah yeah yeah right i feel like it's a
little condescending as well of like i'm
not gonna like whatever you have i'm
bringing this from home
it's a dick move to me i mean some rem
when you get to a certain level
rush like does gallagher's have hot
sauce in there i would say no
hot sauce isn't for like good food it's
for like street food chicken fingers
tacos sure burritos sure
that kind of [__] like i was putting hot
sauce on his sriracha on a steak where'd
the place you guys go you and the reuben
off porch where'd you go peasant peasant
peasant no they don't no hot sauce i
would yeah yeah they're not bringing it
you know they're not like what about
like tgi friday's in them they have they
got a bottle of something on the table
don't they pass goes okay yeah yeah
that's a [__] [__] move not a
[__] move but yeah that's that's
garbage
yeah it's not classic and it also means
that you're only eating in places that
that would have hot sauce like if you're
bringing your hot sauce to a [__]
place to like a nice restaurant that
doesn't have their own hot sauce that's
insane i think taking it to me taking it
anywhere is proper crazy if you went out
on a nice date you and the wife and
another couple at a nice restaurant you
know maybe like a nobu or a [__]
gallagher or something like that and the
and the dude pulled out hot sauce
what did i was with yeah oh we'd move
tables i would be that would be the end
of that that
my wife does it it is it isn't on the
other it is an old school thing you know
i bet you we know a lot of people that
do it
i bet you a lot of i bet there's some
bozos out there that do it
my wife we go to this uh every time
we're in germany we go to this uh
erichian i believe it's pronounced
african uh restaurant in frankfurt okay
it's really good it's a mother and a son
own it and run it and it's like [__]
it's one of those things that comes out
of like a big circle and like you take
the bread and it's just piles of stuff i
gotcha ethiopian food yeah but i think
it's a i think it's this is a reach but
it's the same concept yeah same concept
as ethiopian um somebody just mentioned
ethiopian food to me the other day i
can't remember who it was that it was
awesome cameron boy you never had it
everybody's going
do yourself a favor
love it eating my hands yeah
uh-huh there you go i hate my
masterpiece it's great it's just a bunch
of little piles of stuff look at this
all that's all different kind of meats
very good patchy much and it's on like a
crate style uh piece of bread that's
what this person said i can't [__]
believe i can't remember who i was
talking to about it um but she sneaks in
and i didn't know
we've gone a handful of times now i just
know that she does it the bird did this
i know your wife yeah wait what yeah
cause some of the stuff's hot
yeah and she
uh
so she sneaks in like a yogurt
that she uses
to put on it but i'll give it to her she
this is our head financier i know
listen we said we go out to dinner with
ted soros or something like that she
can't be ripping out a [__] thing of
chobani i don't care what were happening
uh but she does ask
she does say hey
it's a little hot
some of the stuff is a little hot and i
need the the you know whatever what kind
of yogurt
strawberry banana
frozen
um
strawberry shout out to strawberry
banana yogurt that's [__] all patty
thought there was
this gogurt's medicine
it's in the little shooter
oh those little shooters there's never
enough of them things um drinkable
yogurt but now we've we've gone so many
times and she she's done it they know
that like she brings it
and listen i could she do it at other
places no no no only there only they
don't have yogurt back there no they
don't have it that's what they would i
know i know
the first time she did it dude she
reached into her purse and pulled out
like a pint of yogurt and i almost
flipped the [__] table dude i was
uh cause also in your new york i i can't
believe you stayed with her to be honest
with you
get a little bit of cash i knew i needed
to thought she was big enough to check
what do you want
[Laughter]
can't be married for money
yogurt money
but also that's a problem
that's a new york thing too
our major city i think it's becoming
you know
the nicer restaurant you're sitting on
[__] top of each other in these
restaurants i [__] it drives me crazy
where like if you sneaky you gotta like
oh excuse me to like get to your seat
it's like they do the bank they do the
bench seats around the thing that's
where you get yeah the big booth and
then they just stack a hundred
two-seaters right and you're like
[__] it might as well be thanksgiving
dinner with strangers yeah i [__] i
feel like they're listening to me
they're hearing me plot they're hearing
me talk [__] about you you know the
whole nine yards jesus
uh what are you gonna do
he's over here at terabytes talking [__]
about foley
get the terabytes now
uh this one's just proper nuts uh this
is from kyle is it garbage to wear
catheter for a road trip so you don't
have to stop and pee my dad drove from
massachusetts to virginia to pick up my
sister from college and refuse to stop
to pee
that's
crazy persons that's what that that
astronaut woman did with the diapers
that's even do you know what a catheter
exactly is you gotta jam that up as
urethra i'm aware it's a medical
procedure and apparently it's like he's
still in a station wagon
with a spork yeah [__] sad it's
painful some of those mouth wipes after
you get ribs it's very painful
yeah that's nuts man
like that's like most dudes who go in
for surgeries
was she wanted or something like that i
mean
just picking her up man that's that's
like that's crazy
that's why bad stuff that's like you've
been a dad for too long
you can't pull over and take a leak
we're making great time
i'm behind a semi i'm drafting here what
a [__] pull over
i'm saving three miles per three connie
here empty the bag will you
that's crazy
i mean if somebody's looking for you if
there was some kind of time constraint
just because you didn't feel i'm not
stopping a p is made a p from stop from
pulling
five minutes park
maybe wait in line whatever if there is
a light we'll pull back out
seven minutes tops like prop that's if
you do a little stretch maybe some of
these or whatever
that's to not have seven minutes in like
a
it's not like you're adding seven
minutes to a 15 minute drive and you're
like oh this is doubling it or whatever
that's got to be a [__] what was it
massachusetts to virginia's got like a
10-hour drive dude just i would have
stopped and stayed the night somewhere
no i would have broken that up yeah i
know and i tell you i was just going to
say that
you do stop way more than i would
driving and i like i like it
yeah on the road so yeah i'm gonna stop
and stretch my legs for a little bit get
out rip
yeah i like
yeah i like to stretch my legs a little
bit it's good it's also good
we're never superhead when we're driving
from city to city we're never super
hemmed up on time and it's like
awesome it was this [__] guy jesus
christ dad maybe you never know also
when we're on the road sometimes it gets
a little too i gotta shake it up because
i'm in there little stale in the car
yeah you might you're on your phone or
your [__] old man nodding off
t-bones t-bone's in the back [__]
hacking you know what i mean he's
hard-wired in
[__] we got tommy [__] little bo
peep doesn't mums the word with that
[__] kiss they're back
yeah and that's fine but sometimes we do
go a stretch of like 40 minutes where it
gets mad quiet and i'm up there [__]
dozing off i'm like i got a [__] you
got the [__] ac cooking i'm over
there like [__] nodding out i didn't
get a great night's sleep i had about
[__] 19 beers the night before i got
rain sounds like on the radio yeah
i'm [__]
yeah it's just like dude i'm like i
gotta [__] whoo let's [__] shock
the system here let's get the [__] out
splash some gold water on my face it's
also like it's not like we're making
laughs and making right we're on a
[__] highway for like 150 miles dude
i've been there man you're just looking
at the same thing and your brain starts
[__] wondering where the caffeine
just stops working
there's only so many cups so i got to
stretch the legs i got to feel the heat
from the outside some fresh air tall and
it also
it wakes you idiots back up oh what a
style what are you gonna get i'm like ah
cool let's do a heater and then we stop
and then we get back in and we start
[__] on the town that we just
stopped in yeah what i mean it's a
conversation and then about 45 minutes
later you guys all passed back out i'm
gonna do it all over again shout out to
barcelona pa barcelona p.a it's all
right walleye tournament you want to go
back for that maybe that's where we go
camping go back for the tourney that's
not a bad idea we go to barcelona i
don't really think i still have the
brochure on me i don't know but did you
see those [__] they weren't amish or
they weren't mennonites
because they hopped out of a car had
normal clothes on but they had the
mennonite haircut and beard which are of
amish haircut and beard kevin they were
dominican
which was appropriate weird vibe
where it's like how do you only hang on
to the haircut and the beard the
haircut's the worst part that's what i'm
saying it looks like you all did it in
the dark together
it's like you're wearing [__] regular
jeans and [__] sunglasses yeah and
you got to [__] hit a haircut
you don't run around with the same jude
cut get out of here
like you did it in your bathroom
i don't get that you're talking about
the bangs that come down to the bangs
and then the jebediah beard
that dude
they those three dudes when we were in
wherever we were those three dudes
hopped out of a a new pickup truck it
wasn't even like a buggy or anything
look at like the schrutz
it was
it was real beat farmer vibes
moe's shout out to moe's
just running next to the car when
they're pulling up to the
was that your was that that might have
been the first introduction of you ever
see that episode i think i know what
you're talking about they're pulling
down and they're like yeah this is
shrewd farms or whatever the most is
just running at full speed next to the
car looking in the window
moses has real uh neighbor from
the burbs vibes remember the sun in that
whole and the sardines sure the sardines
[__] saltine crackers sammies
let me ask you this let's take it up a
notch let's get in the contest yeah of
course i'm not going to [__]
tailgate the wall i'm getting in there
i'll get a captain let's do it
let's go we'll get the fishing license
and everything i think we just missed
[__] yeah you said it was coming up
thank god i didn't feel like doing any
of that [__] but let's do a fishing
tournament that might be the next thing
we'll do like a proper
fishing tournament
i know a couple guys who could do a deep
sea fishing tourney what are they biting
on skittles
i was in a deep sea fishing tournament
and that's when that first
first time the only time uh i saw
gallagher live he was the entertainment
for the show and he walked out it was a
very
fancy very expensive uh fishing
tournament was he doing on the boat no
it was like there was like a huge tent
for entertainment it was like a big
buffet and then a huge one like hugh
like
[__] football field size
you know
that's gallagher and probably selling
tickets back he was just [__] taking
out bite-sized snickers and a tennis
racket and whaling them into the crowd
and just [__] beaming people in the
head i remember being like this guy i
was like 13. i'm like this guy's past
his prime i think
this is a money grab for this dude these
new bits yeah i'm like his heart's not
in it man i can tell smash the
watermelon they can let's go get on the
roller skates let's do it when i pay for
the new crap oh man
doggy
this one's from uh
i can't even pronounce it transylvania
or something like that is it garbage to
you this one guy this one kind of blew
my mind is it garbage used the cardboard
carrier from an old six-pack as a
condiment organizer in the fridge
that
is the smartest thing i think i've ever
heard
it is that's they kind of do it at like
bar like pubs or whatever
oh six pack all right i'm thinking
twelve pack of cans that's just a box in
the fridge oh man that's bad you guys
will use a shoe box you have to go
you're like oh really shoe box you got a
[__] set of nikes in there
huh but if i went for a [__] gold
miller light and there was cucumbers or
something
i'd freak out
no six packs so it's like yeah that's
cool that's that's smart because that if
you keep them on the door and there's
not enough if you keep it's real jiggly
they fall it's it's not fantastic i'm
doing this when i get home that's
something you've got all this on my my
place for a yogurt
you gotta you gotta keep those fresh
though you can't just that's not that's
not a one one that's not for the whole
summer not monthly probably monthly
spills or whatever you know yeah
um
hachimachi that's a really good idea
that kind of blew my [__] my tits off
big debate that's been going on over at
the foley household is uh
is it trash to just set the toilet paper
on top of the roll
well not because obviously yeah but when
you but it's it's better no it's trash
no listen it's better to [__] roll it
in your hand i know do you want my
opinion on i understand where you're
going because sometimes it pulls it rips
i like [__] just right in my hand do
my i know but then the prob the issue
with that is everybody's [__] fingers
are all over that thing the left hand
doesn't have [__] fingers
listen it's you're getting poop on your
left hand i'm not getting poop what are
you
what are you wiping with both hands no
i'm just saying but like that's your
gran you're handling a thing that
shouldn't be handled that's my that's my
germaphobe thought process on it is you
should just pull
rip if everybody is pooping let's say
you got a house full of foleys all going
in there you're not [__] you're not
sanitized you're not doctors in there
you're not scrubbing in and out all
right
a lot of pass oats over here it's there
it's a lot of poop particles floating
around to me i don't like it if you go
into a public stall and that's sitting
there i'm going
i'd like that better i don't have to
reach for it it doesn't pull what do you
reach for this is crazy i understand
what you're saying but like you actually
have to reach for it it's it's never on
the other side of the room you don't
have to waddle over to it it's [__]
right there
toby
is your toilet paper thing
on the toilet paper dispenser
yes with an asterisk oh
so it's on the thing but the way my i
use my hand
[Laughter]
told the paper
but the way that the door opens it opens
in front of like it's it's the toilet
paper rolls across the door when you
poop you live alone no okay so that
one's just for show but i got i got the
real deal on the back of the toilet
there you go there you go oh you used
the one on the back of the toilet that's
fine wait
let me just say this can you reach the
toilet dispenser from your toilet i
could if the door was closed
which is not wait if the door was closed
so it caught the door covers it yeah
that's trash
yeah he can't reach yours
it's by the sink
holy [__] i also made the move of buying
like a giant thing of like 35 rolls of
toilet paper off amazon or whatever
that's just that's just bags right there
just right on the floor
yeah yeah of course for sure for sure i
trust me i'm not saying i'm uh you know
not
uh i don't fall victim to that sure
especially in in the moment
because
i don't think in the moment you reach
her
let's just say you go into the bathroom
the rolls on the thing like on the spool
right you run out whatever and you go to
recharge it's rare i would assume i
don't think i've ever like put it on
while i was pooping that's
just getting sat down while until i
finish my business and then i probably
will leave it there until i go back in
or whatever until it really clicks and
i'm like what am i doing and i throw it
on there okay it's a sense of like uh
we get you know those the empty ones too
for whatever reason that the the trash
can in the bathroom like
never really clicked have you ever gone
just wipes have you ever run into toilet
paper not not replied it not refreshed
it
but the wipes are still in there i don't
like it oh i go i i've done i like i
need to dry off i feel really yeah
otherwise i'm [__] slipping out of my
seat all juicy though yeah i don't like
it sorry i like it
uh i gotta i gotta yeah i don't do the
wipes though really no dude wipes i
don't know if i can say that
i don't think you're allowed to either
but i'm a fan
are we i don't think so
i wouldn't say we are
let's see where the chips fall you know
what i mean let's see what a turkey is
i could be um all right this is john
among your family photos on display is
there a photo of a relative at a random
famous person's grave
hahaha that is bad
dude i just thought about that yesterday
randy rhodes is [__] tombstone or
something that's a [__] tough look
roddy roddy piper's mausoleum
shout out to the piper
no disrespect bobby
um
i thought about that because i was
listening to the doors yesterday i was
getting that's a big one i think they
still hold up and we went to [__] jim
morrison's grave in paris
yeah and i thought that that's trashy
did you take a picture in front of it of
course really yeah doing [__] air
guitar
[__] melting some faces over there
babe [__] plug me in
i don't know if we took a picture of
that i think we took a picture in front
of edith pilof but i think that's that's
classy who's that is that a dessert
a pilaf isn't it got coconut
i mean i think i know you're a big
dessert guy but god damn if you're
thinking about it
hunting down the inventor of your
favorite [__] treat the guy who
invented the banana split
jenny jimmy splits i'm weeping at his
grave
like a widower um
you're thinking of pilaf rice
yeah this one this is a french woman i
believe she's french edith pilaf she was
a singer
if i'm not mistaken she's the one that
sings the song
it's just weird you keep saying i'm not
sure if i'm not mistaken it's really
good to the woman's grave that you don't
know anything about well she's famous
right
the lady the bird knows her i thought
she invented the pull-and-peel
twizzler was her idea to put the fruit
by the foot
everybody else was doing inches she said
let's do it by the foot
no the bird likes her we went to a
couple there's a bunch of famous people
buried at this one at this at paris
cemetery um
[Music]
[__] was i going to say oh i believe she
sings the song in saving private ryan
that they're listening to remember she's
saying french i could be wrong on that
but she's one of those type people she
has that kind of vibe that kind of voice
okay yeah
yeah that's garbage man that's garbage
although
going to graceland wouldn't be a bad
idea
go see the king
he didn't i don't know it never
really what ah fox was an elvis [__]
two days ago shout out to burning love
yeah i don't know i just it's so johnny
cash
i understand kenny rogers
um that's also old person music to me
you don't want to go to the gym
temptations smokey robinson who i've
seen live in concert
i'll go to smokey's grave um he died
[__] owe me money
i think smokey's all right little
richard maybe there you go now we're
talking there you go i'm dumb down let's
go
we were more of a motown family of
course we were too we were motown all
the way motown and oldies none of that
beetle [__]
yeah no no i don't think my mom even
knows who the beatles are my mom patty
was not a fan of the beatles at all
you dropped [__] in or the stones to be
honest with you
it was more old school
yeah big bobby diron household the
broad's like the old the incredible
crooners is what they're called yeah
they were crooners
[__] cleaning up back then
[__] frankie valley doing dances out
at the lake just closing
in 1955.
she still runs in the door every time
she hears one of those
this one's from brian ever been arrested
on a date i was pulled over for speeding
then putting a holding cell for writing
a bad check my date bailed me out i
should have married her holy [__] you
[__] should have you you should have
man that's a ride or die broad right
there first date
i mean yeah i would i mean he had a
warrant out for writing a bad check
and they could i was pulled over for
speeding and putting a hole in himself
for writing a bad check wow yeah
damn yeah he probably had a bench ward
out or something
i don't know something got jammed up
that's
yeah that's it right there that's a bad
look man that's tough you can't you but
that's also one of those things like if
she does stick around then it's true
look because she's seeing that you're
[__] worse that's what i'm saying
yeah she should have [__] married her
speaking of stories if any listener has
ever been put into the holding cell of a
stadium [__] send us that [__] a lot
of philly people have yeah i'll tell you
that right now the vets was famous
he's [__] famous
my brother's boy got sent down there for
getting into a fight we went to a
phillies game one time [__]
nosebleeds at the vet with my dad on a
sunday afternoon or that was 700 level
brutal
yeah it was that was a different that
was a different breed of people oh it's
like the outer rim the 80s and 90s
phillies were
absolutely reminds me i want to bring in
the piece of the vet i have
it's a big rock i don't know where we're
gonna put it
i forget how [__] just philly dirtbag
i truly love the batting cage my mom
won't throw it out
it's been in my garage since the day
that they blocked it's not getting
tossed out no and she's yeah i remember
we're not throwing that that's the
retirement fund
that's my nephew's college we had a
piece of the berlin wall for a little
while my mom berlin new jersey
[__] out of here no you did it
none of you left the country until like
[__] three weeks ago a roommate of
mine brought it back to jail
he only charged me five grand
ah yeah yeah yeah it's berlin it's the
wall
you're nuts
man you got bamboozled betty started how
many magic beans did he give you too
i picked it up out front
patty's telling everybody we got sputnik
in the garage
um
uh is it garbage if your dad's stepdad
and brother are all named rodney
that's a it's not a good look
rodney's a good name though right
rodney's going and then what we were
playing with at was it pittsburgh
randy randy zara randy's are all
there's very few classy randys i would
say did i ask the guy
what randy's a short form for like
probably randall i mean probably most
most randy's are just named randy yeah
that's uh i keep forgetting about about
uh
randall
but i would assume if you're rocking
randy
you probably are probably a rocking
randy says all right your mom dated him
he'd get a cream soda at that place it's
sure
randall randolph as well as bertrand and
bird trained
i don't like when i don't like when they
flip up the name like that that's the
candy's not short for android that's
like old southern [__] right there
no bueno
we should do a patreon level where one
of us has to legally change our name to
randy
how much money would it take i just
would i don't have to go to the dmv wow
i'd be a pain in the ass
but i do it for free guys that's great
that's a good pretty sweet yeah
you have to grow your hair out once you
once you change your name to randy randy
foley randy ryan's oh that's pretty good
no randy ryan
we're on to something we're on a rainy
round sounds like a horror from high
school
hey i'll go back
i'll re-enroll baby
i just picture like uh
yeah like so like um
the duke boy's cousin whatever daisy
duke
that's like a randy ryan kind of wow
i only knew the jessica simpson version
of it
duke's a hazard friday night
what year was that i feel like you
watched
you know duke's a hazard i remember
watching in the meantime now prime time
what year was that out i was probably it
was probably 80 81 really i thought it
was all i guess i thought it was older
yeah probably 80 81 82 maybe yeah that
and hee-haw watch t-haul
like oh yeah first edition i remember
when the muppet show was on we'd gather
around the tv to watch those little
[__] the way you talk it sounds like
it's in black and white and you listen
to fireside chats from the from teddy
roosevelt or whatever everybody get
around the [__] ronald reagan's
fireside chat vision here whoa okay
okay
we're gonna have to we're gonna
we're gonna have to have a creative
meeting fire my vocal coach yeah
and talk about up-to-date uh up-to-date
impressions with age foley here
that's funny all right now hit jefferson
go
fast car
um
all right let's see here
uh this is from anthony
uh have you ever have you or anyone you
know gotten a gift card to a vape shop
for your birthday
man those vape shops are just
not cool nobody's doing the big ones
anymore right
i i think it's f i think the jewels are
have
taken over and in new york you can't do
the fruity [__] anymore uh somebody just
sent me something that they're outlawing
all uh
vape
style stuff like you're not allowed like
the jewels everything's gone really it's
new york no i think like nationally
they're pushing for it
it's got these kids hooked these kids
aren't smoking but they're drooling
they're vaping all of them partying and
then that leads to heaters because
that's like [__] analog jewels you
know it's a real old-school shirt it's
the real deal so now all these kids are
puffing [__] stingers space
cigarettes yeah you know who's loving
that philip morris yeah not me i broke
them all that's true hippie's been off
to bernie's kevin ryan's guide to
quitting smoking
just give me 10 grand and i'll tell you
uh this one's from alex tennelle shout
out to alex and hello up there in
bastion ah mr tanello shout out to mrs
tanello as well shout out to the
tanellas have you ever bought the floor
model of a shoe
yeah recently i just did it too it's a
bad you gotta really look to see if it's
faded you feel like a dirt bag i feel
like there's mustard on it because you
get like [__] mouth breathers coming
from the food court with general celsius
there's definitely poop particles all
over that shoe oh yeah that's no good i
don't uh
that's a real tough [__] look to do
that it really is it sucks man they get
jammed up they only have what size are
you
uh ten typically depending on the
depending on the model yeah i go 11 and
a half they usually but 10 is typically
the floor model that's where you get
jammed up or like 10 10 and a half is
like because that that looks
proportionately normal like a 10 and a
half like not on a body you look at that
and you're like oh i can picture myself
in that yeah if you put a 13 out there
people are like what though
it's this place permit for that thing
it's called jacks what's going on
ah the boots that you guys made fun of
me for that look like lady boots the
ones i bought in series were lady boots
that you bought in syracuse then yelled
at me that you bought women's shoes for
some reason
they were four battles yeah yeah i mean
when you were at a dsw everything is a
four mile all right
they got you in the back working
uh
i have found a couple of gems
there what's the deal with those places
they fall off a truck what's going on
it's like that is is it the stuff that
hasn't moved elsewhere or is a bit
defective i would presume it didn't make
the you know
two left feet rolling around yeah
[__]
just going you going there gonna set up
these crushers dude some of those boots
in there right
are there of control snow boots have
gotten [__] way out of hand huh
somebody's gotta take them down to pega
though get rid of their twitter or
whatever you gotta i'm not climbing the
matador this weekend dude i've seen
pairs of those in dicks like who are
these for a wookiee what's going on
it's crazy
nothing i mean that was the most [__]
80s comic delivery i ever one of these
for all wookiee
all right whatever
for the rest of the show well no i agree
i'm sorry it was funny
um but
dsw
this is my take i'm not the you know
i'm not the most stylish guy around i
don't claim to be okay i i click yeah
shout out to the black t-shirts
uh
i wore a i wore a gray one last week or
two weeks ago someone goes damn kippy's
tropical um casual friday but i can
dress i mean for this it's whatever
jeans and a t-shirt i can dress to
whatever situation you don't gotta prove
yourself i'll give it to you you do have
a little bit of an eye for fashion thank
you i go to you
and you don't listen clearly
um no i just like i can operate in world
sure i mean i can go to an event or
whatever and not look like a [__]
bozo which i am but
use dsw to try to find
something spec you go there for a find
you go there for not going there for
your [__] everyday shoes or whatever
no i only use those places if i'm if if
the wedding's tomorrow and i ain't
[__] doing it you gotta get shoes
who's yelling at you my mom your mom's
you're 46 your mom's yelling at you but
she's reminding me that i need shoes
that's the suits at the house but you
got to get shoes and a belt
that's the only time i go to dsw that's
night before the sats sure or you i'm
set or i'm saying you can find some nice
gems in there every now and then
something that's typically not there you
get there for 50 off or whatever i would
like to start kicking docksiders again
the slippers the slip-ons yeah yeah
they're not bad pair of sperry's spare
these are all right maybe the light blue
ones i feel like be a little too
yeah small on you it would look like
you're wearing ballet shoes because you
know those nice polo sneaks that i have
the white ones
debatable but sure
what that they're sneakers or that
they're nice that they're nice
they've started to bow out
oh yeah they're leaning oh when you know
i mean like you can tell a fat man is in
them it's like can't you buy wides i
don't want wads i don't want to no what
do you mean okay i'm asking i don't know
what you're saying you're falling out of
your shoes no i'm saying that they're so
worn in that like you can like they've
they've broken
like the i know i understand running
shoes don't do that
they gotta really really dig in there
okay yeah tough luck on that
bad when it's when you when you're not
in them that's when you see it like when
you see him over by the door you're like
god damn who's [__] shoes of this
like they're mine looks like two kayaks
it looks like a cow was walking around
in them literally
and he was technically oh
man okay i'll do a
something like that sounds good this one
from jasper 10 home we've touched on
this before is it garbage to reuse
grocery bags to carry your lunch to work
it's a tough look and i think it depends
on your commute
yeah if you're on the subway and you got
you know that's a tough look i feel if
it's tupperware in there you can tell
yeah i just feel like a use first of all
those bags have a shelf life of about
from the store to the house now if we're
talking about the reusable bags they're
giving out at the grocery store these
days i've seen you get on a plane with
those goddamn right uh that's a little
only new york's doing that that's a new
york thing oh really yeah yeah new york
and maybe like philly or something oh
they're sweet i love it target does them
in new york yeah no i think target does
them everywhere a little the reason
we're talking about they're all right
man maybe they do maybe they don't but
i'm saying you put anything in there
yeah as far as i'm concerned i i believe
you um
the second you pull out like from under
the sink out of the bag out of the
plastic bag that holds the bag it's like
it looks like it's you [__] you hit
it with an egg beater it's all [__]
crippled up you look and then you're
you're expecting dog [__] to be in there
yes exactly the way i l i view it is
like
you're what is the way i feel like i'm
walking out of the house i'm going to
work i got my shirt my tie i have a pair
of slacks i got my [__]
my laptop whatever kind of work dude
though
i'm in an international business dress
to impress and then you're just carrying
like a wrinkled bag with an orange and
you know some penne vodka and
you're like
it just it doesn't last night's best
look like a bozo yeah i feel like it
just ruins all the hard work you did of
like doing your hair
this guy is a shmelvin you know yeah
they had those cute little coolers now
those little soft coolers that was all
yeah that's tough for me i have weird
things with i can never take my lunch to
school really real nerd [__] why i don't
know
even as even in a brown paper bag as an
high school kid throw it in your book
bag you don't got to think about it no
we bought i bought all the time man
yeah all right i am what i am and then
those lunch boxes they would have they
all smelled the same even as a kid you
didn't have a lunch box
i was doing uber eats getting delivered
no i did but i know we i would brown
paper bag it is because i hated the
lunchbox i had a he-man one i [__]
loved it
no the the lunch boxes were no longer
cool when it was the lunch pouch
like yeah you're [__] you got that's
we talked about that the largest pouch
like the velcro and they all it was like
kind of like a cooler they [__] suck
your generation did a lot of [__]
wonk they really upped everything like
this we talked about the cereal bowl
with the straw in it
i think that was my i think that was
after me all that nickelodeon you kids
were watching
oh i'm sorry we weren't watching hee haw
and [__] gilligan's island or
whatever the [__] you were doing
good episode of hill street blues
sitting in on a live audience live
taping in the ed sullivan show
you [__] loser
[Music]
[Laughter]
i literally wish i could like
shoot a movie of how i picture your
childhood and some of the some of the
things you tell me
that to me are like my mom experienced
you know what i mean like that's
we're at it we're at an age where we
grew up kind of like
you your upbringing was probably closer
to my dad's than mine a little bit yeah
because you're just advances in
technology i think i think from the from
when i was a level of income
yeah we didn't have cable what about it
[__] up there with rabbit ears
wow hbo we've only freed six channels up
until he just did six channels he had
six channels
yeah of course i mean we don't we still
don't have cable upstairs we didn't get
cable until i was i think 14 was when we
got cable we had we we did have
i told you those movies back there we
had got hbo for like one day and my dad
recorded everything he could on the on
the vhs and then real sex i bet too
a bunch of taxi cab confessions
[Laughter]
he's down there
she's down there like he was kodiak
[__] getting that thing done or kodak
um
[__] what was i saying yeah for the
first
from zero to like five six
i think would be lean towards more
towards your parents generation and then
after that once like the mid 80s once
the 90s hit i think it makes it similar
but i was like 14 15 by the way yeah
yeah yeah 100
yeah it was old stewed i remember asked
me if i listened to elvis
well it doesn't matter
taste in music
it sure does you said you listened to
the motown motown was he elvis and
motown existed at the same time
it was his later years
when the pills yeah i mean they they
still play motown at weddings and stuff
they're not [__]
well
is a big hit suspicious minds
at a wedding last night when was the
last wedding you've been to and they've
played
elvis and not motown i don't think i've
ever been to a wedding where they played
elvis i went to a wedding last week when
they played kentucky rain where was this
wedding
i would have had to been there down the
street
walking by you guys got any elvis back
there
am i throwing it all so i could win a
bed it's going to play the
yeah jukebox
was it was real 80s the first five six
years of my life was like really
you know was [__]
it was different yeah it was different
it was real weird i feel like everything
was everything looked like old cheers
yeah it was real poor 80s too yeah you
guys didn't have like fax machines and
stuff what yeah no
no
we didn't have a telephone until
i was not kidding that reminds me my mom
tells the stories that they had the
party lines where the half the block
would be on the same phone
so that's wild they would pick up the
phone and then like they're like oh we
got to hang up the mcmullens are on and
it's like okay let me know when you're
done there was only like two phone lines
for the whole block what yeah oh that's
what your stories feel feel when you
tell me stuff no we weren't going down
to the general store to get the news
yeah i mean that was poor philly just
watching morgan mindy like a gentleman
yeah
but let's wrap it up we got to wrap her
up gang good stuff not a hot one baby a
fun one a silly one hot one a fun must
gang uh don't forget
august 11th we're gonna be in red bank
new jersey
those tickets will sell out gonna sell
out wanna give you the heads up yeah
make sure you get them grab a little
merch have a good time see you next week
we love you peace